Yeah,
I increases she not to
be coming from music.
You had intense
environmental interventions.
We should consider the possibility
that these differences have a genetic
component.
And that really began the incendiary
descent of intelligent search to the
periphery,
to the reaction against
that was universal.
Uh,
because it implied inferiority,
if you believe,
it seems like
it's also something
that's universally hated,
but on both sides of
the political spectrum.
Because on the liberal end,
you know,
the idea of fundamentally is,
is that everybody's the same.
And that if you,
if you distribute education,
resources,
property,
then everyone can succeed.
And so that didn't work
out so well for liberals.
And then on the conservative side,
the idea is,
well,
if you could just get off your
lazy ass is and get a job,
there is a job for you out there.